[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde les batailles écologiques à
venir les conflits se multiplient sur la
planète guerre en Ukraine et ailleurs au
Proche-Orient en Afrique et partout où
le terrorisme et le nationalisme se
nourrissent de la radicalisation
religieuse des esprits et de
l'intolérance politique mais il est des
conflits qui ne disent pas leur nom et
qui nourrissent l'égoïsme et la
compétition effrénée des nations les
guerres écologiques autour de l'accès à
l'eau de la sécurité de la souveraineté
alimentaire et de l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans ce domaine qu'on
pourrait qualifier déco stratégique tout
se tient à en vérité car comment
dissocier le cycle de l'eau de la
production d'énergie et de l'industrie
agroalimentaire comme de la consommation
des aliments dans la mesure où les
interférences avec le climat l'économie
la de l'environnement la stabilité des
sociétés la paix des nations sont
étroitement imbriqués par ailleurs face
au gaspillage consumériste au risque de
pénurie aux catastrophes naturelles la
notion de sobriété s'est imposée au même
titre qu'un accès équitable et partagé
aux ressources et aux innovations de
progrès nous allons en parler avec mes
invités que je vous présente alors Jean
zouzel vous êtes Paléo climatologue du
GIEC vous avez même obtenu le prix Nobel
alors que vous étiez directeur
scientifique et vous êtes directeur de
recherche au CEA madame Sandrine
Rousseau vous êtes député de Paris
écologie et nupes
Magalie reggaiza zit vous êtes maître de
conférence en géographie à l'École
normale supérieure Emmanuel galicher
vous êtes enseignante chercheuse au CNAM
et Jean de kervas Douai vous êtes
économiste de la santé et ancien
directeur des hôpitaux
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir deux citations
l'une de Régis Debré chimère n'a plus
Dieu pour les prolétaires mais pour les
ruminants et une citation du comédien
Philippe Torreton les appels citoyens se
heurtent à l'inertie mortifère de nos
dirigeants on va commencer par là est-ce
qu'on serait passé de la primauté
sociale à l'injonction écologique les
avis sont partagés mais votre quel est
votre sentiment sur la gouvernance
écologique de la planète et la passivité
supposée de nos dirigeants qu'en
pensez-vous Jean jauzelles d'abord je
crois qu'en terme
dans d'écologie de transition écologique
il faut revenir aux associations
scientifiques c'est une réalité c'est
une nécessité un peu pas imaginer un
monde dans lequel la neutralité carbone
ne serait pas atteinte alors je crois
que ça je crains que ça soit trop tard
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
à un degré 5 mais ils ont ne pas
atteindre neutralité neutralité carbone
effectivement accepter l'idée que le
climat se réchauffe indéfiniment il faut
bien comprendre donc d'abord ça s'appuie
sur une réalité scientifique alors de
notre côté nous avons eu effectivement
du côté de la communauté scientifique
nous avons beaucoup de difficultés à
faire passer cette idée de la nécessité
d'une transition à la fois vers le grand
public vers disons nos dirigeants bien
que
disons là la convention climat des 92
fixe comme objectif de stabiliser le
réchauffement climatique ce n'est qu'à
Paris qu'on parle d'une stabilisation
avec un objectif chiffré voilà l'accord
de Paris donc c'est tout cela ne
démarche
bon il y a eu quand même du côté des
dirigeants et j'aime bien le dire une
prise en compte des messages du GIEC en
ce sens par exemple que bien on parle de
neutralité carbone à horizon 2050 et
plus d'une centaine de pays l'ont
inscrit d'une façon ou d'une autre dans
leurs objectifs le problème ce n'est pas
mais c'est ce n'est que dans les textes
c'est à dire il y a un fossé vraiment
entre ce qui est inscrit dans les textes
y compris dans notre pays et la réalité
c'est ça le grand problème
donc oui on a je crois qu'on a essayé en
tant que communauté de faire passer nos
idées on y arrive ça prend du temps nous
sommes désormais dans le
mot clé du sixième rapport du GIEC c'est
le mot certitude nous sommes certains
que
l'ensemble ou quasiment l'ensemble du
réchauffement climatique est lié aux
activités humaines nous sommes certains
que nous allons vers un réchauffement
qui risque d'être important si nous nous
prenons pas garde on part plutôt vers 3
degrés donc c'est tout cela notre
discours qui mais notre discours notre
constat je dirais il y a une écoute mais
on est loin entre l'écoute et sur la
réalité alors Sandrine Rousseau on vient
d'entendre la position scientifique
est-ce que vous pensez que les
dirigeants en font pas assez ou en font
trop et lesquels
Acton qui n'en font pas assez puisque là
on est sur une trajectoire de 3 degrés
les chances que l'on reste en deçà de
1,5 sont ça fait blisse et fonde comme
voyage au soleil et ce qui me frappe
vraiment énormément depuis que je suis à
l'Assemblée j'ai l'habitude de dire que
je n'ai jamais été aussi écho anxieuse
que depuis que je suis à l'Assemblée
nationale parce que en fait ce qui me
frappe c'est le déni complet qu'il y a
de la représentation nationale sur la
question climatique s'il y a on gère la
question climatique
éventuellement dans une loi sur
l'énergie ou dans une autre loi sur un
autre sujet environnemental mais on ne
gère pas la question climatique comme
préalable à tout débat sur le système
social sur la résistance d'un système
social sur le l'évolution du pouvoir
d'achat sur le logement sur la sécurité
sociale et en fait c'est et quand je le
pose ou quand nous sommes quelques-uns
le poser on nous prend vraiment encore
aujourd'hui en 2023 pour des
hurluberlues et ça on a un sujet on a un
sujet et d'ailleurs la locution du
président de la République m'a fait
signé de ce point de vue c'est-à-dire
qu'il avait des mesures très précis sur
les questions économiques sur la santé
par contre sur l'écologie c'était on a
changé est-ce que vous voulez dire qu'il
faut tout
faire partir du climat
l'économie vous connaissez aujourd'hui
le danger est tel aujourd'hui le danger
est tel que on devrait s'interroger sur
l'effet de chaque mesure que nous
prenons sur le réchauffement climatique
et la perte de biodiversité toutes les
décisions que nous prenons devraient
être à l'aune de sa compte on étudie un
texte sur les retraites il y a une étude
d'impact qui est adossé à ce projet de
loi on pourrait discuter de ce qui était
cette étude d'impact peu importe mais là
il y avait une étude d'impact et bien à
la ligne impact sur l'environnement il
était noté néant
alors que travailler deux ans de plus
c'est produire 0,5 à un point de plus de
PIB donc ça a un impact sur
l'environnement et en fait on ne lit pas
les choses et aujourd'hui à la source
vraiment à mon avis d'un très gros
problème qui s'appelle le déni du
caractère systémique de la crise face à
laquelle nous sommes on est tous
d'accord sur ce déni Jean de kervas
non pas vraiment parce que je pense que
personne ne nique la température
est de ni la page je pense ici le
rapport du GIEC néanmoins je crois qu'il
est important avant de commencer ce
débat de rappeler une chose assez simple
c'est que l'écologie dépend d'un
écosystème donc on a un écosystème
planétaire et donc les questions du
climat sont planétaires mais les autres
questions de l'écologie dépendent d'un
écosystème et notamment la question de
la biodiversité dépend d'un écosystème
spécifique dans un endroit spécifique
sous un climat spécifique on ne peut pas
en parler en général je pense que c'est
à tort on résume ou qu'on réduit les
problèmes de l'écologie
à la question du climat Magalie regazith
vous vous occupez au mystère de la
recherche de tous les sujets sciences
humaines et sciences sociales est-ce que
le climat impacte chacune de vos
disciplines alors je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs choses dans ce qui a été dit
et qu'on mélange un peu tout c'est à
dire qu'effectivement ce que montre le
rapport du GIEC c'est-à-dire ce que
montre la science c'est qu'à un moment
il y a des limites dures au
développement de tous les êtres humains
sur la planète c'est limite dur elles
ont été posées c'est d'une part
effectivement le niveau de réchauffement
on sait qu'au-delà de 2 degrés on entre
dans des
dans des incertitudes telles que ça
devient compliqué et que on a de moins
en moins de capacités d'adaptation
notamment pour les plus défavorisés pour
les plus démunis y compris en France
c'est pas juste des problèmes très loin
de nous on a aussi notre limite dure
c'est effectivement l'effondrement de la
biodiversité on sait par exemple la 3
degrés on est à 20% du vivant qui
s'effondre et derrière cette
biodiversité ce sont des risques
boomerang pour la santé humaine pour
l'agriculture parce que sans
biodiversité on peut pas cultiver on
peut pas manger etc donc ça c'est le
cadrage ensuite effectivement derrière
il y a cette idée de se dire est-ce
qu'on clime assise tout et je pense
qu'il y a à malentendu dans ce cas
expliquer madame Rousseau et peut-être
ça peut être intéressant de discuter
là-dessus c'est que d'une certaine façon
c'est limite planétaires que sont
effectivement le climat la biodiversité
etc doivent devenir des cadres
méthodologiques c'est la nouvelle règle
du jeu c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'on va sortir de ses limites en
réalité on va mettre en place des
politiques qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre à moyen court au long terme vont
se retourner contre nous et là
effectivement arrive la politique ce que
dit le rapport du GIEC et ce que dit
aussi le rapport du Haut Conseil pour le
climat qui évalue les trajectoires de la
France c'est que oui il y a des choses
qui sont faites c'est que non on ne va
pas assez vite et que ce qui met les
scientifiques aujourd'hui dans une
situation
de colère et d'impuissance c'est que les
solutions existent elles sont évaluées à
nouveau sur la base de la science elles
sont faisables accessibles elles sont
finançables en revanche qui manque
derrière c'est justement le politique
parce que c'est pas une fois qu'on a dit
le politique au sens d'un débat d'un
projet avec derrière des valeurs qui
sont différentes parce que le chemin
pour atteindre ses objectifs de
décarbonation il va supposer des choix
des priorités et le problème qu'on va
avoir dans cette histoire c'est que
justement je reviens à la question peut
me poser les scientifiques aujourd'hui
sont sommets
de se substituer de par leur expertise à
des décisions qui sont des décisions qui
devraient être prises de manière
démocratique y compris et là je
m'adresse au médecin vous êtes en train
de dire que les politiques entravent la
puissance d'agir des scientifiques non
les scientifiques ne sont pas là pour se
substituer aux politiques le médecin ne
dit pas si c'est lui qui est le malade
doit se soudre
allez-y
pardon mais enfin pour vous répondre sur
le fond il y a les politiques
écologiques voilà ça on a des débats sur
la trajectoire énergétique etc mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus prendre une
politique publique on ne peut plus
prendre la décision d'une politique
publique sans en regarder les effets sur
le climat et la biodiversité et c'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui ça n'est
absolument pas fait absolument pas fait
et on considère que ce sont des domaines
qui sont étanches les uns avec les
autres alors qu'évidemment que non et
cela c'est dans ça qu'on n'a pas une
vision à mon avis
pas suffisante de la gravité de la crise
qui arrive parce que si on en avait une
clairvoyante sur l'ampleur de cette
crise alors toute euro publique que l'on
dépense aurait une espèce d'étude
d'impact sur les effets sur ses effets
sur le climat sur sa préservation ou pas
sur la biodiversité et sur la quantité
d'eau enfin sur l'ensemble des
pour le téléspectateur c'est pas très
clair finalement qui entrave
d'en faire plus dans ce domaine
sur la planète donc commençons oui mais
on peut parler de la France et de la
planète
nous sommes pas les seuls sur la planète
et l'évolution du climat va dépendre de
nombreux pays à commencer par l'Inde les
États-Unis et d'autres pays mais si on
veut revenir à la France le problème
c'est que les écologistes politiques ont
agi contre l'écologie et notamment
contre
le réchauffement climatique en étant
ennemi depuis l'origine du nucléaire on
va en étant en empêchant que l'on
fabrique des OGM en sciences au
réchauffement climatique et à la
biodiversité la meilleure manière de
sélectionner des plantes c'est quand
même de faire parce que je suis Serge je
me suis occupé beaucoup d'hôpitaux dans
ma vie mais j'ai fait aussi la gros les
deux forêts donc j'ai quelques vagues on
va rentrer dans le détail
non mais c'est quand même important à
mon avis de rappeler que les écologistes
politiques ont agi contre l'écologie et
qui se sont ils se sont
deux exemples
j'ai certainement pas et encore heureux
que on les appelle soutenu mais les OGM
c'est de la technologie sur le vivant
s'il y a c'est pas ça de la préservation
de la biodiversité la préservation de la
biodiversité c'est de préserver la
qualité des écosystèmes pour qu'il y ait
justement une forme d'équilibre ça n'est
pas des reventer de notre vie
qui a l'agriculture a sélectionné des
plantes et à faire
d'autres avis Emmanuel galicher est-ce
que vous dans votre enseignement au CNAM
vous prenez en considération ce prima du
climat évidemment on le prend tous les
jours dans toutes les formations
aujourd'hui en français c'est devenu
quelque chose de central notamment chez
les ingénieurs puisque aucune formation
d'ingénieurs ne doit éviter la question
du climat mais cette question du climat
elle est trop vague en disant juste il
faut parler du climat en fait tout est
corrélé évidemment ça c'est je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord là-dessus aussi
bien les usages de l'eau si bien
l'énergie l'énergie est partout tout le
monde en a besoin et elle permet aussi
d'avoir des usages de l'eau correct
l'agriculture a besoin d'énergie et
d'eau donc vous voyez que en fait il
faut avoir une stratégie une vision long
terme c'est peut-être là dessus
finalement que on est en train de
discuter c'est que les politiques
doivent prendre en compte les Expertis
scientifiques ça il y a aucun doute mais
surtout ensuite il doit donner une
stratégie une vision à long terme de
comment on arrive à un but et
aujourd'hui tout est un peu noyé parce
que les politiques ont un peu la tête
dans le dans les étoiles en se disant
mais je sais pas qu'est-ce que je dois
faire etc la première chose c'est ce
soir autour d'une table et de trouver
une vision long terme avec une stratégie
avec des étapes pour arriver à cette
note finalement cette neutralité à
carbone en 2050 je crois que si vous
faites à l'interview de n'importe quel
politique il est pas sûr que vous
trouviez quelqu'un qui se dit il faut
faire ça en 2010 en 2020 ça en 2035 donc
la stratégie est pas mise en place
je me mets à la place du télé-spectateur
à écouter ce qui vient d'être dit il
comprend pas d'où vient la lenteur à
aller plus voilà vous avez côtoyé les
grandes ce monde est-ce que c'est eux
qui freinent est-ce que c'est est-ce que
il n'y a pas de corrélation entre
sciences politiques industrie qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'on n'arrive pas à avoir de
meilleurs chiffres dans ce domaine
d'abord on m'a invité à parler du climat
mais donc je l'ai fait tout à l'heure
mais je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
dissocier le problème du changement
climatique de l'ensemble du mode de
fonctionnement de société c'est ça qui
est très important c'est à dire on ne
peut pas dissocier le climat d'Emmanuel
Lady de la biodiversité du cycle de
l'eau de la sécurité alimentaire on peut
pas non plus le dissocier
disons de ces aspects sociétaux en
termes de Basset d'emploi de ces aspects
économiques et même de ces aspects
culturel c'est très clair donc c'est
quoi quand on parle de neutralité
carbone je crois que bon
forcément ça irrigera le monde le mode
de fonctionnement le développement de
nos sociétés au cours des prochaines
décennies sauf que c'est bien tout cela
je je suis intéressé à la transition
écologique aussi en particulier au titre
disons d'un rapport sur l'enseignement
de la transition dans l'enseignement
supérieur et bien c'est clair que c'est
cette vision globale de notre société de
cette transition qu'il faut prendre donc
c'est vrai que je suis invité à parler
de climat alors pourquoi ne pas ne
va-t-on pas assez vite pour le climat il
y a quand même alors d'un côté
je suis en phase voilà je suis en phase
avec les objectifs de la France tels
qu'ils sont inscrits dans la loi je me
suis intéressé donc un objectif un
objectif disons division par 6
ne traiter carbone en 2050 ça me va très
bien le problème il n'est pas dans les
objectifs affichés il est dans la façon
dont on ne respecte pas quand on regarde
on y reviendra peut-être on est à 20%
d'énergie renouvelable on va remettre à
24 % comment va-t-on aller vers 32 ou
plus de voilà on y reviendra mais voilà
donc je crois que il y a une stratégie
nationale bas dans lesquelles toutes les
étapes sont bien inscrits oui mais il y
a 18 mois vous disiez la même chose ce
qui montre qu'il y a une continuité dans
votre pensée tout à fait mais ça mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que on affiche des objectifs et on
triche sur leur réalisation oui je le
crains en tout cas
je crois que c'est le diagnostic Magalie
pour un eurodire du conseil pour le
climat on va passer vite probablement et
même notre président a dit qu'on allait
pas deux fois qu'il fallait doubler le
rythme de diminution d'ici 2030 comment
fait-on donc c'est reconnu ce n'est pas
disons c'est sur la place publique oui
nous n'allons pas aussi vie assez
je voudrais prendre les problèmes les
uns après les auteurs Magalie regga zit
je voudrais vous poser cette question
concernant l'eau actualité violente avec
la fameuse bassine de sainte Soline
est-ce que l'agriculture française
a-t-elle besoin de ses réservoirs d'eau
et d'une manière générale y a-t-il un
risque de pénurie d'eau alors déjà on
confond tout oui parce que la sécheresse
c'est pas forcément la pénurie
la sécheresse dans le désert il y a pas
de risque le problème de la pénurie
c'est que vous avez un déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande dans un
climat qui change et on l'observe déjà
depuis la décennie 90 2018 en gros à
partir de 2002 ce qu'on appelle l'eau
renouvelable en France c'est-à-dire
l'eau qui est pas évapotranspirée l'eau
qui est à disposition elle a baissé
globalement sur la France d'à peu près
15%, 15 à 14 %. donc vous avez une offre
qu'on peut utiliser sur un territoire
pour faire très simple bon l'offre
baisse de l'autre côté notre demande
sociale elle est très haute et elle ne
cesse d'augmenter et dans un climat qui
change parce qu'on a des été plus chauds
et plus secs il va falloir notamment à
certains moments on va avoir besoin
d'eau pour irriguer par exemple parce
que vos végétaux même des végétaux qui
ont pas besoin d'eau en temps normal il
faut les irriguer on va peut-être avoir
besoin d'eau pour refroidir la ville on
va peut-être avoir besoin d'eau pour
hydrater plus donc on va avoir des
besoins d'eau qui peuvent augmenter dans
le temps et donc vous avez des demandes
qui augmentent et vous avez une offre
qui baisse à partir de là ce que dit la
science c'est simple 1 il faut
effectivement faire ses réserves d'eau
pour les moments vraiment critiques mais
deux si on ne regarde que cette
stabilisation de l'offre alors que notre
offre elle baisse structurellement ça
marche pas et donc l'idée c'est de
trouver localement les solutions qui
vont permettre de répondre à ces besoins
d'eau pour éviter justement la pénurie
en essayant d'un côté un
d'être le plus efficace possible dans
notre consommation et deux de faire ce
qu'on appelle la fameuse sobriété c'est
à dire d'éviter les usages qu'on juge
non essentiels et pour ça on a une boîte
à outils et donc je prends l'agriculture
on va pouvoir effectivement agir sur les
variétés on va pouvoir agir sur les
espèces on va pouvoir agir aussi sur la
manière de produire de cultiver mais on
va devoir aussi agir sur nos
consommations donc ça veut dire agir sur
les chaînes de valeur agir sur les
chaînes productives et puis derrière il
va falloir se poser la question on a
construit par exemple ces fameuses
bassines qui ont pour caractéristiques
d'aller chercher l'eau dans les nappes
c'est ça qui pose problème celles qui
sont construites elles sont construites
est-ce que c'est une solution d'avenir
de construire partout et surtout le
territoire ces infrastructures qui sont
énergivores ou l'eau peut s'évaporer
ça va dépendre et en gros à chaque fois
à chaque fois qu'on fait ce type
d'infrastructure on devrait se poser la
question est-ce qu'on n'a pas une
solution qui est plus efficace et qui
est meilleure parce que sinon c'est ce
qu'on appelle la mal adaptation
qu'est-ce que c'est que la maladie
adaptation ce sont des solutions soit
qui verrouille nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre typiquement la
climatisation soit qui empêche des
transformations plus profondes qui nous
mettront à l'abri dans un climat qui va
continuer à changer tant qu'on n'aura
pas atteint la neutralité carbone de
cette disponibilité en eau qui va
baisser quoi que l'on veuille de manière
chronique Jean de kervas
je suis d'accord avec ce que vous dites
mais pas du tout avec le ton que vous
donnez parce que vous inquiétez à mon
avis inutilement à ce stade alors
attendez alors à ma connaissance
j'ai écrit un livre sur l'eau aussi donc
j'ai quelques vagues notions sur ce
sujet j'ai construit des barrages etc
donc à ma connaissance
quand il pleut en France 64% de l'eau
s'évapore tout de suite 34% s'infiltre
et nous rejetterions 176 milliards de
mètres cubes
s'il y avait aucune activité humaine en
France de fait nous en rejetons 171
milliards donc la différence nous en
rejetons le fait dans les fleurs les
fleuves dans la mer en fait la
différence et notamment notamment
l'irrigation en France ce n'est que 3
milliards de mètres cubes et ce chiffre
baisse le taux une augmentation les
centrales techniques et les centrales
nucléaires c'est un milliard et le reste
un milliard donc je pense que vous
inquiétez de manière
inutile nos téléspectateurs en laissant
croire que on a aucune marge en laissant
croire que il y a pas d'eau dans les
nappes phréatiques orientes des réserves
absolument collées
statistiques
c'est faux je suis désolé de vous dire
il faut aussi
vous parlez d'abord d'un climat je sais
pas quand est-ce que vous avez fait vos
études mais ce climat n'existe plus ne
va pas évoluer deuxièmement vous
reprenez un argument climato-sceptique
et de dire que l'eau qui va dans les
fleuves et perdu et vous prenez un
problème d'échelle qui est effectivement
un problème très compliqué c'est qu'en
fonction du niveau national du type de
territoire et de l'échelle les modèles
vous avez le droit d'être en désaccord
ça me paraît compliqué mais néanmoins
quand vous regardez les statistiques le
problème c'est il est assez simple à
dire quel est l'impact météo
c'est-à-dire et quelle est l'impact
climatique bon quand vous regardez les
statistiques météorologiques en France
vous voyez que l'année la plus sèche du
20e siècle c'est 1920
quasiment 14 mois sans plus donc nous
sommes encore quand on regarde la
distribution c'est à dire la moyenne et
les quartiers on est encore dans les
variations météorologiques alors moi je
lis la rapport du GIEC je pense que
effectivement il y a une évolution des
extrêmes et qu'on est en train de
changer et la moyenne et les quartiers
mais pour l'instant et en plus un
certain nombre de modèles de prévision
climatiques prévaut que on aurait plutôt
un excédent d'eau dans les zones
tempérées Sandrine Rousseau et puis non
mais surtout
là on est typiquement dans ce à quoi on
se confronte en fait c'est à dire que on
a des gens qui viennent nous expliquer
alors qu'ils sont pas chercheurs qui
sont pas politiques voilà et qui
viennent nous dire voilà on a 34% on est
10% avec un ton traddock et qui nous
disent bah voilà il y a rien à faire et
en fait c'est ça le climato-scepticisme
aujourd'hui c'est en fait et c'est un
vrai sujet de comment on le contre parce
que derrière il y a des intérêts
économiques des rapports de domination
aussi pardon de le dire mais enfin là ça
me semble assez flagrant par ailleurs et
donc comment on change notre structure
sociale et si on s'intéresse à l'eau en
fait il certes on peut discourir des
bassines mais la question profonde c'est
comment à quoi sert cette eau et
pourquoi on en a besoin et donc l'usage
de ces bassines en l'occurrence c'est
l'agriculture est-ce que l'on peut
conserver le modèle agricole tel qu'il
est actuellement dans un dans un système
météorologue
pourtant ben oui mais enfin qui ont de
plus en plus d'eau donc en fait la
question c'est comment on fait en sorte
de diminuer la quantité d'eau et pour
cela par exemple la culture qui est la
plus contestée c'est celle du maïs dont
on sait que c'est une des cultures qui
nécessite beaucoup d'eau mais c'est
aussi l'élevage par exemple et donc il y
a besoin de revoir c'est en cela que je
vous disais tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
une vision systémique à avoir c'est à
dire que quand on a une et je prends ma
casquette de politique quand on a une
loi sur l'alimentation et bien on doit
aussi interroger les décisions que nous
prenons sur l'alimentation en regard de
la consommation d'eau que cela nécessite
et on regarde et des de l'évolution du
système climatique et de biodiversité et
là on n'y est pas par exemple on a eu un
débat sur la quantité de viande dans les
cantines où il était manifeste que il
n'y avait pas de volonté de modifier
cette consommation de viande et pourtant
ça fait partie des gestes qui modifient
qui ont un impact sur la quantité d'eau
dont nous avons besoin en agriculture et
en élevage ça dépend de la manière dont
les vaches
écoute le débat on peut pas laisser un
débat trop technique vous voulez vous
emmêler les gens je vous aiment est-ce
qu'il y a pas assez d'eau ou est-ce que
non mais
mais même si les mêmes dans les régions
où les précipitations resteraient
constantes ce qui se passe dans le
réchauffement climatique augmente
l'évaporation c'est très clair donc il y
a un déficit et je suis complètement en
phase avec Magali il y a un déficit de
15% par rapport à une période par
rapport à l'eau disponible ensuite
du point de vue de l'hydrologue je suis
pas mais la meilleure façon donc de
garder l'eau si on la considère quand
même bien commun c'est la laisser
rentrer dans les sols alors après on
peut voir le point de vue de
l'agriculture c'est autre chose mais il
faut bien se placer est-ce qu'on
conserve l'eau pour une utilisation
optimale pour l'ensemble des
usages ou bien est-ce qu'on privilégie
un usage c'est un choix qu'on peut avoir
qui est un choix de société mais il faut
bien comprendre que du point de vue du
cycle de l'eau la meilleure façon de la
conserver c'est de la laisser rentrer
dans les sols alors on parle on parle
d'une solution miracle avec le recyclage
des eaux usées alors on cite certains
pays est-ce que c'est vraiment en France
c'est 1% donc j'ai intervenu à peu près
de l'ordre de 1% c'est pas beaucoup donc
oui c'est bien de le faire moi je pense
qu'il faut le faire on est très en
retard par rapport à d'autres pays y
compris l'Espagne mais c'est pas ça qui
va nous sauver par rapport aux 15 % et
qui ont été cités par Magali regazza
vite bon écoute
on mettra pas tout le monde d'accord sur
la question de l'eau on va essayer
d'avancer et cetera des milliards et
néanmoins des milliards d'individus
n'ont pas accès ni à l'eau potable il y
a une alimentation saine ne dispose pas
de l'électricité il manque de sources
d'énergie et on s'aperçoit que pour
certaines populations il y a un cumul de
ces difficultés qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire de ça Emmanuel caliché et c'est
évident que si on regarde la situation
planétaire aujourd'hui elle est
dramatique elle est pas dramatique chez
nous en fait elle est dramatique dans
les pays sous-développés ou
effectivement il y a pas d'accès
électricité un homme sur un être humain
sur neuf sur neuf pas d'électricité
encore aujourd'hui donc en fait on a
aussi nous en tant que nation
industrialisée et de haute technologie
des responsabilités envers ses jambes
du réchauffement climatique c'est pas la
faute du réchauffement climatique c'est
la faute d'un pays industrialisé qui ont
peut-être
penser qu'à leur exploitation et qui
aujourd'hui
doivent effectivement à nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre diminue dans les
pays industrialisés mais vous voyez que
les pays en développement augmentent
c'est normal ils essayent aussi de
sortir de la pauvreté et donc
l'électricité est aussi un bien commun
et doit être un bien commun mondial
autant que l'eau et ils sont absolument
corrélés parce qu'on parlait justement
des eaux usées pour devenir une eau
potable c'est absolument énergivore le
dessalement de l'eau de mer aussi est
une technique qui est utilisée en Israël
qui utilisait dans beaucoup de pays en
Espagne et qui est absolument énergivore
donc vous voyez qu'à chaque fois c'est
bien ça où il y a une vision stratégique
à avoir et je suis d'accord avec Madame
Rousseau sur le fait qu'il faut à chaque
fois qu'on prend une décision regardez
ce que ce qui va impacter autour de nous
et l'énergie l'eau l'agriculture tout
est corrélé finalement donc il y a
intérêt aujourd'hui à ce que les pays
industrialisés donnent l'exemple déjà je
pense avec des énergies décarbonées donc
mettre la priorité sur les énergies
décarbonées et puisse donner des
solutions technologiques au pays qui
n'en ont pas les moyens en fait est-ce
que vous dites Rousseau de ce dialogue
Nord-Sud avec la pénitence d'un côté et
le gaspillage de l'autre est-ce que
c'est aussi facile et moi je pense que
ça va être le grand sujet des années à
venir s'il reste que l'on continue à
s'accaparer des ressources et des
technologies et en faire profit et du
coup à laisser une partie du monde à
l'écart de la transformation écologique
absolument indispensable dans ces pays
là où est-ce que l'on est dans une dans
un partage dans une dans une coopération
et dans une reconnaissance de notre
responsabilité qu'elle soit historique
ou à l'heure où nous parlons et en fait
aujourd'hui c'est un peu à mon sens
l'impensé des discussions alors les pays
moins riches essayent de les mettre sur
la table des négociations dans toutes
les cops avec des fonds de compensation
des fondées etc mais à la fin les pays
riches rechignent à reconnaître leur
responsabilité et historique et dans le
moment de de
perruches comme la France qui polluent
c'est le premier pollueur et la Chine le
deuxième des États-Unis le troisième
Blade spécialement déjà c'est pas vrai
historiquement et c'est pas vraiment
en France autant qu'un chinois en
moyenne de démission de gazon exactement
le passant à un sujet peut-être qu'il
fasse mais peut-être que vous serez
d'accord là-dessus alors il y en a pas
en matière d'énergie des carbonée si on
prend le mix énergétique français il est
fait de nucléaire et d'énergie
renouvelable bon on n'est pas comme les
Allemands on attendait attendez attendez
attendez attendez attendez attendez
essentiellement il y a du reste aussi
mais on a en tout cas on n'a pas autant
de charbon et de lignes que les
Allemands est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour considérer qu'il que pour la France
il y a pas d'autres solutions
qu'une qu'avoir amix énergétique avec du
nucléaire des énergies renouvelables de
l'hydraulique également et un peu du
reste
mais évidemment non mais ce sera sans
surprise
que vous feriez quoi madame il y a
toujours cette ce non dit dans tous les
débats énergétiques qui est la question
de la sobriété c'est-à-dire comment on
diminue massivement nos besoins
énergétiques et en l'occurrence le
nucléaire qui est présenté comme une
espèce de technologie presque magique
qui résoudrait nos problèmes un peu
comme les bassines un peu comme les OGM
un peu on pour moi c'est vraiment de
l'ordre de la pensée magique
c'est-à-dire que parce qu'on
construitait quelques centrales alors
finalement on se sortirait de cette
question énergétique évidemment pas et
par ailleurs les centrales nucléaires
ont absolument besoin d'eau et on voit
bien que les sécheresses les sécheresses
font que on va manquer d'eau est-ce
qu'il y a besoin de de d'utiliser de
l'eau pour refroidir des centrales et
encore de la question oui mais celles
qui sont au bord de la mer sont en zone
submersible c'est le cas de Gravelines
par exemple qui est une des principales
d'Europe et qui sont
si c'est construit sur un bol d'air
c'est à côté de Dunkerque
est un polaire bien sûr que si
en fait l'adaptation de des centrales
nucléaires et de l'industrie nucléaire
est en marche et donc notamment à
Gravelines il y a une digue les gens
d'ailleurs les gens là où ils habitent
disent que si par hasard il y a un
problème d'inondation tout le monde va
aller se réfugier dans la centrale parce
que justement c'est le seul endroit qui
ne sera pas inondé donc
si une inondation dans le Nord vous
aurez beaucoup d'autres profitez-en
Emmanuel pour dire ce que vous pensez
est-ce qu'il y a un autre choix alors il
faut il faut faire il faut faire une
très grande différence entre un mix
énergétique et un mix électrique
aujourd'hui
on est en train de parler il y a plus de
nucléaires dans l'électricité que dans
l'énergie il y a 70% et 25%
le combat c'est absolument fondamental
aujourd'hui des pays industrialisés et
même des autres c'est de sortir des
fossiles quoi qu'on fasse c'est les
énergies fossiles qui nous embêtent
d'accord qui sont la base de tous nos
problèmes donc quel que soit chaque pays
a le droit de faire le mix qu'il veut
nous il se trouve qu'on a un mix
électrique largement nucléaire de fait
de notre histoire et donc du coup nous
avons une je dirais une petite avance
par rapport à certains autres pays du
fait qu'on a 92% de notre électricité
qui est décarbonée ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut s'arrêter là et dire yes on a
tout fini ça veut dire qu'il faut aller
voir là où il y a du charbon du pétrole
et du gaz et de le remplacer par des
énergies renouvelables et des énergies
décarbonées c'est ça notre combat c'est
rien d'autre
si vous venez au pouvoir si vous arrivez
au pouvoir dans quatre ou cinq ans et
qu'on a relancé le nucléaire avec 6
paires de plus
6 autres qui suivront est-ce que vous
démantelez vous
de la situation française et que
l'électricité le Pr qui est actuellement
construction et toujours pas en activité
qu'il a connu des retards sur retard qui
a des fissures et que en fait
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de père qui
fonctionne correctement donc
misé sur une technologie et par ailleurs
je reviens quand même sur Gravelines on
va faire on va faire une non mais celui
de Finlande étant et enfin je comprends
même pas en fait pourquoi vous vous
revendiquez scientifique et que vous ne
regardez pas la réalité sur le sur le
nucléaire
centrale de Gravelines elle est entourée
d'une digue c'est vrai elle est sur un
pôle d'air c'est à dire que en fait le
jour où la mer monte et bien il va tout
un triangle entre Dunkerque et qui
arrive presque jusqu'à Armentières sous
l'eau et on aura notre centrale
nucléaire qui sera certes avec une digue
on parle pas des événements climatiques
extrêmes et qui sera avec une digue et
au plein milieu de la mer enfin quelle
est pourquoi ne pas vouloir développer
davantage des énergies renouvelables
type éolien type solaire par exemple on
a eu tout un débat à l'Assemblée
nationale sur le fait que il y avait une
majorité dans l'assemblée qui ne voulait
pas mettre des panneaux solaires sur les
toits déjà existants pourquoi en fait
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça gêne de
mettre des panneaux solaires sur les
toits déjà existants et pourquoi ne
faisons-nous pas cet effort là de
technologie qui sont finalement légères
plutôt que d'aller vers des EPR dont
l'avenir est quand même encore un
certain désolé de le présenter comme ça
mais aujourd'hui c'est quand même un
réel
[Musique]
le modèle français fait que
l'électricité pour 70% et produite à
partir du nucléaire est-ce que vous
pensez sincèrement qu'on peut inverser
cette chose-là ou ramener à 50 % bien
sûr que je le pense vous vous le pensez
bien sûr et vous en je vous aime moi
j'aime bien m'appuyer sur le rapport du
réseau de transport d'électricité
une première conclusion importante c'est
que la France n'atteindra pas neutralité
carbone sans un développement
significatif de renouvelable c'est la
conclusion la plus importante pour moi
la deuxième c'est effectivement ce
serait plus facile c'est les points 4 et
5 du rapport rtuel ce serait plus facile
si on conduisait si on construisait
disons de nouvelles centrales nucléaires
mais il faut bien partir du fait que ce
qui est important aussi c'est le
développement du renouvelable je ne suis
pas du tout anti-nucléaire mais à un
moment il faut aussi on y arrivera pas
disons atteint notre a été carbone même
avec les 14 EPR sans un développement
massif de renouvelable qui ralentit
actuellement par exemple pour l'éolien
terrestre c'est très clair on a beaucoup
de retard de nouveau sur l'éolien en mer
on parle de projet mais ce sont des
projets qui prendront du temps et c'est
peut-être aussi ça qu'il faut mettre en
avant donc évidemment je pense que
l'important maintenant ça l'électricité
c'est 25 enfin 25 % ou 30 % de notre
énergie c'est comment on fait pour
remplacer les 70% il faut de la sobriété
effectivement sur une pouceau là disons
redit mais je crois qu'il faut
effectivement développer ce mix
énergétique de façon intelligente mais
pas en abandonnant le renouvelable
disons ou le développement massif du
renouvelable je le redis au bénéfice du
nucléaire il faut je crois développer
les deux en tout cas mais c'est pas ce
qu'on est en train de faire c'est ma
crainte on a pris je redis on devrait
être à 24% de renouvelables on est à 20%
et si on avait été à 24% nous aurions
moins de problèmes face à la disons au
problème énergétique posé par l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie
effectivement vous avez totalement les
mixtes doivent diversifier toujours ça
c'est une des conditions sinequanone
après les EnR aujourd'hui on se trouve
devant une problématique d'opinion
publique qui est assez importante et qui
fait qu'on n'arrive pas à le développer
et je pense qu'il faut absolument aller
au-delà il faut aller faire de la
pédagogie auprès des populations pour
qu'on puisse développer très fortement
notamment l'éolien à offshore qui a un
bon un bon coefficient de disponibilité
et qui permet de faire d'électricité
dans les moi je veux bien je voudrais
rebondir justement aussi sur ce sur la
rte et sur ces scénarios à 2005 pour
2050 en fait donc il a il développe 6
scénarios dans lequel en fait il diminue
donc on doit faire moins 40% quand même
de consommation énergétique donc la
sobriété l'efficacité énergétique et
ensuite dans toute cette chose là il y a
l'électrification des usages et ça c'est
fondamental si on veut des carboner
notamment notre industrie qui est
extrêmement carbonée aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on sacrifie donc il faut qu'on aura
aujourd'hui on va passer de 35 pour cent
le minimum c'est 35 % voire 60% de plus
de d'électricité à l'horizon 2050 ça
veut dire que les EnR ont toutes leurs
places l'hydroélectricité on va faire
attention parce que là sécheresse bon si
on a des pertes d'eau évidemment nos
lacs nos barrages sont beaucoup plus bas
et on a des problèmes sur l'électricité
hydroélectriques et le nucléaire en fait
partie ce sont trois solutions qui sont
absolument incontournables merci
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir cette citation
de Simon voyez un auteur de roman
policier peut-être pour vous mettre
d'accord l'homme a voulu vivre en
société mais aussi depuis qu'elle existe
l'homme emploi une bonne part de son
énergie à lutter contre elle alors l'eau
l'énergie la sécurité alimentaire en
partie liée par l'économie l'écologie la
solidarité quel lien de parenté
établissez-vous entre eux notamment dans
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique Jean de cœur vaste
moi je voudrais revenir ce qu'a dit
Jean-Joseph tout à l'heure parce que
c'est
un peu si vous voulez
Dubosc disait penser globalement agir
localement je pense qu'on peut avoir en
permanence en tête
le réchauffement climatique mais on est
obligé d'agir localement et donc les
actions en France ou même en ce qui
concerne l'eau
en Bretagne ou en amont de Toulouse ou
sur le couloir au Daniel ne sont pas les
mêmes comme les femmes ne sont pas les
mêmes les
politiques agricoles donc je pense
qu'effectivement on s'oriente vers des
moments très très difficiles je partage
avec vous et avec beaucoup d'entre nous
ce que vous avez dit sur les problèmes
Nord-Sud je pense que les sommes
milliards je crois oui 900 millions 100
millions bref ne sont pas suffisants et
que
on voit bien et on va voir encore cette
année se développer
la liaison que je vous propose est-ce
que vous pensez que tout ça est lié et
le réchauffement climatique les relie
encore plus
je pense que malheureusement il ne faut
pas trop globaliser parce qu'on ne sait
plus comment agir donc on est obligé
d'avoir obligé d'avoir des hiérarchies
donc si on prend on considère que le
réchauffement climatique est l'objectif
central de l'avenir de l'humanité
ensuite on décline avec d'autres
objectifs qui sont
la survie des gens leur santé
l'alimentation etc etc mais
malheureusement ce qui mène le monde
aujourd'hui c'est quand même beaucoup
plus l'économie et à mon avis ça va
continuer à l'être c'est beaucoup plus
l'indépendance des pays c'est beaucoup
plus les guerres déclarées ou latentes
donc je ne suis pas d'un optimisme fou
un Galilée là-dessus sur cette liaison
en fait elle est posée désormais dans le
rapport du GIEC qui démontre très bien
que dans un monde trop réchauffé par
l'homme ou dans un monde où la
biodiversité s'effondre l'atteinte des
objectifs de développement durable
c'est-à-dire du bien-être humain qu'on
soit au niveau mondial ou au niveau
local pour tous c'est impossible et qu'à
l'inverse et c'est ça tout le paradoxe
c'est que il existe des formes de
transition donc des choix et des
arbitrages qui font que on peut
atteindre tous ces objectifs climatiques
avec ce qu'on appelle des copines et le
rapport de synthèse du GIEC qui vient
d'être publié en fait démontre action
par action secteur par secteur tous les
co bénéfices qu'on peut avoir en termes
de santé d'alimentation et donc en fait
l'idée derrière c'est quoi c'est de se
dire que face à un climat qui change les
plus vulnérables sont ceux qui cumulent
le plus d'inégalités c'est en fait
scientifiquement démontré
la situation
et ce qui est extrêmement injuste et là
on en arrive au sentiment et donc à la
réponse politique c'est que derrière les
coûts de transition portent pour
l'instant sur les plus c'est à dire
qu'en fait c'est la double peine quand
on va mettre des mesures pour essayer de
réorienter ce sont les plus démunis qui
sont au départ le plus fragiles c'est ce
qu'on voit chez les agriculteurs d'où
l'idée qui est développée dans le
rapport du Haut Conseil pour le climat
de mesure structurelles on reprend
l'exemple des agriculteurs le jour où
les agriculteurs fabriquant selon des
principes plus écologiquement vertueux
énergétiquement sobriété de sobriété en
sol en eau ça sera plus ça le sera
rémunérateur par rapport à faire
autrement
téléspectateur se pose si on prend la
France d'aujourd'hui
qu'il s'agisse de l'énergie qu'il
s'agisse de l'alimentation et d'autres
sujets on est en baisse par rapport à au
décès ni précédentes il y a 20 ans on
disait que notre cm mix énergétique
notre système énergétique était
flamboyant sur le plan agroalimentaire
on est dépassé par une nation comme
l'Allemagne comment vous explique les
Pays-Bas également comment vous
expliquer cette chose là
ça dépend ce qu'on est passé là aussi on
est dans un discours qui est double et
qui est pas celui des scientifiques il y
a la question
il faut tenir compte de l'économie oui
mais justement il y a la question du
plus c'est la question vous avez dit
tout à l'heure nous avons un système
agricole qui depuis 1980 nous avions 2
millions d'agriculteurs en 1980 nous
sommes aujourd'hui à 400 000
agriculteurs voilà donc la question
c'est est-ce que ces agriculteurs
aujourd'hui on en a moins ils vivent
beaucoup mieux avec beaucoup plus de
confort ils ont des
problèmes et donc ensuite la question du
problème ce que peut faire le
scientifique c'est dire quoi et c'est si
on fait ça si on fait ça si on fait ça
on va dans le mur parce que on sait
scientifiquement que telle solution
n'est pas tenable dans un climat qui
change ou dans une biodiversité qui
s'effondre ensuite ben ensuite il y a
des priorisations et c'est bien là tout
l'enjeu de la politisation c'est à dire
que ce que vous dites est très juste on
est dans des sujets qui ne sont
finalement pas inscrits et je ne le dis
pas en contre des hommes politiques en
particulier mais qui ne sont pas
inscrits à l'agenda parce qu'autant
discute d'économie d'école en France
vous avez 67 millions de spécialistes de
la pédagogie on est tous enseignants
tout le monde sait comment il faut
éduquer les gamins ça on en parle c'est
pas compliqué mais alors par contre sur
le climat c'est trop compliqué on voit
les plateaux tolérant rempli de gens sur
l'Ukraine mais par contre quand il
s'agit de parler de climat on dit que
vous comprenez c'est compliqué le
télespectateur il s'en rendent pas
compte excusez-moi mais ça fait partie
aujourd'hui de la même donne que le
vieillissement de la population
qu'effectivement
économique je voudrais avoir votre
sentiment politique Sandrine Rousseau
qu'est-ce que vous pensez d'un certain
déclassement de la France je pèse mes
mots sur la production agricole sur
l'énergie où on était quand même en
meilleure santé il y a deux ou trois
décennies
que je sais que l'économie vous parle
oui puisque ce qu'on vous intéresse
avant d'avoir avant d'avoir un mandat
mais poser la question en ces termes
c'est poser
la question dans les termes du monde
d'avant c'est à dire c'est on fait
toujours plus plus et c'est booking on
n'est pas sûr que finalement ce soit lui
qui les dit mais qui dit à une
croissance infinie dans un monde fini et
pour croire qu'une croissance infinie
dans un monde fini est possible il faut
être soit fou soit économiste et bien
voilà et là à gouverner il y a une
réelle qui est là non mais le réel ça
n'est pas de faire de ce d'être dans une
forme de de classement par rapport aux
Pays-Bas ou à l'Allemagne le réel c'est
de se dire comment on assure
l'autonomie alimentaire de la France et
comment on le fait avec une des méthodes
agricoles qui permettent et de préserver
l'eau et de préserver les vers de terre
parce que c'est par exemple la quantité
de vers de terre dans nos sols c'est
absolument effondré et c'est dramatique
et comment et donc c'est comme ça qu'il
faut non bon on va pas autoriser les
glyphosate c'est comme ça qu'on pose
qu'on doit poser la question et
justement
cette manière de poser la question de
dire on est en train de de perdre perdre
du champ vis-à-vis de machin ou de c'est
une réalité économique mais non en fait
ça n'est pas le sujet principal en fait
le sujet principal c'est comment là on
construit une France qui est résiliente
face au réchauffement climatique à la
perte de biodiversité et ça pour cela il
faut pas poser la question de savoir
est-ce qu'on est en rang 1 ou en rang 2
ou en rentrant il faut se dire de quoi
on a besoin en terme d'alimentation et
comment on s'assure qu'on a eu deux
années
qu'on avait on a eu sur le plan
énergétique auparavant avec beaucoup de
biens qui manquait donc il faut se
préoccuper de l'industrialisation de la
guerre d'Ukraine
c'est un peu connexe mais pour moi un
des sujets ça a été qu'on n'a pas été
capable de se priver de gaz russe en un
temps très court de sorte que et bien on
n'a pas réussi à mettre la pression sur
la Russie de manière suffisante et que
on est dans la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes
en coupant les vannes du gaz et on en
achetant plus c'est pour ça qu'il y a
vraiment quelque chose de l'ordre d'un
modèle de résilience à penser et on
n'est pas du tout là-dedans parce qu'on
est dans un modèle de croissance et non
pas dans un modèle de résilience on va
conclure et je voudrais conclure en
reposant une question
politique j'avais dire à chacun de vous
parce que
dans les le différent entre la France et
l'Allemagne on parle d'autonomie
stratégique de souveraineté stratégique
et si on applique cette souveraineté
stratégique à l'énergie à l'alimentation
le président de la République parle dit
on va reconquérir notre souveraineté
stratégique sur le plan alimentaire sur
le plan énergétique alors brièvement
chacun avec quelques secondes vous y
croyez Jean je vous aime et à quel à
quelle échelle de temps et est-ce qu'on
a les investissements nécessaires pour
les technologies
idoine et permettre cette souv côté
alimentaire
énergétique énergétique on en a parlé je
crois que souveraineté alimentaire on la
garde quand même on peut quand même la
garder avec le système français il faut
aussi dans les deux cas je crois aussi
bien en termes de gaspillage alimentaire
que ils ont de sobriété énergétique le
mot sobriété et aussi un peu essentiel
donc c'est cela mon sentiment donc
effectivement il faut peut-être que nous
fassions collectivement un peu plus
attention à notre comportement par
rapport à l'alimentation par rapport à
l'utilisation d'énergie maintenant je
pense que
il faut absolument que je le redis la
loi et là mais il faudrait que nous
prenions de véritables mesures pour
tenir les engagements et je crois
franchement que et bien divisé par deux
nos émissions de gaz effets de serre par
rapport à 90 en 2030 c'est maintenant et
il faut aller deux fois plus vite et
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut agir c'est
ça le message c'est pas ce qu'on va
faire dans 20 ans dans 30 ans c'est
important les investissements à long
terme sur les mais c'est qu'est-ce une
feuille d'ici 2030 pour tenir les
engagements qui sont divisés par deux
nos émissions par rapport à 2030 bien
sûr la souveraineté alimentaire est
importante également je fais souvent des
conférences dans le monde agricole je
crois qu'il y a quand même besoin
d'adaptation de l'agriculture aux
conditions du réchauffement climatique à
l'accès
énergétique elle est absolument
incontournable évidemment mais elle va
demander aussi une transition sur les
les elle va avoir un des problématiques
géopolitiques sur les matières premières
ça on en a pas beaucoup parlé et ça va
être absolument dramatique si encore une
fois la France on n'a pas une stratégie
pour être à des endroits clés absolument
incontournables la Chine l'a compris
elle a elle a toutes les matières
premières elle a toutes les processus de
transformation de l'industrie
sur les matières premières alors Magalie
et Zazie sur ce point pour conclure et
en fait cette transition c'est justement
aussi d'une des clés de la souveraineté
si nous ratons la transition nous
perdrons forcément au niveau mondial et
de la crédibilité et surtout cette
capacité à encore décider pour
l'alimentation pour l'eau pour en fait
tout toutes les ressources dont on va
avoir besoin donc genre de cœur basse
oui je suis d'accord si ce n'est que
quand on regarde la balance des paiement
agricoles on se rend compte qu'elle ne
serait déficitaire s'il n'y avait pas le
vin l'alcool et voilà et donc on a une
baisse de la production agricole qui se
traduit par une importation en France du
fait d'un certain nombre de règlements
discutables et c'est ça ma critique de
l'écologie politique et non pas
d'écologie c'est que l'écologie
politique elle a agi contre l'écologie
et elle agit contre l'écologie en se
battant contre le nucléaire elle agit
contre l'agriculture en interdisant les
OGM si on s'intéresse au ver de terre il
faut autoriser le glyphosate parce que
ça permet de faire des cultures sans
solde etc on peut continuer donc il faut
pas merci on vous a écouté alors
Sandrine Rousseau vous vous êtes pour
une souveraineté alimentaire
souveraineté énergétique vous y croyez
pour vous mettre dans un musée parce que
je pense qu'il y a quand même quelque
chose je leur de la pureté de la pureté
dans votre raisonnement
mais oui le musée ici je pense que
dans l'archétype des trentes glorieuses
mais là il y a vraiment l'enjeu c'est de
la souveraineté c'est la résilience en
fait et là à la fois il nous faut
diminuer nos émissions de carbone
préserver notre notre biodiversité il
nous faut aussi nous commencer à nous
adapter et je pense que aujourd'hui ça
fait partie des politiques qui nous
manquent et donc plus que de
souveraineté je crois que nous avons
énormément besoin de résilience et de
politique publique de résilience
on arrive à la fin de cette émission je
voudrais vous présenter une brève
bibliographie alors Jean Josel vous avez
publié
climat itinéraires d'un pionnier édition
Ouest-France un entretien avec Paul
Goupil vous considérez toujours comme un
pionnier oui je sais pas oui c'est vrai
que j'ai une certaine antériorité où je
travaille sur ces domaines depuis plus
de 50 ans mais je sais pas si on les a
fait avancer suffisamment rapidement
alors Magalie regga zit vous avez écrit
avec Stéphanie Beucher la géographie
pourquoi comment vous n'avez pas le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'on parle
beaucoup de géographie avant on était on
parlait beaucoup d'histoires et
maintenant la géographie venir
rééquilibrer un peu le terrain j'espère
on y travaille
c'est une très belle discipline mais je
pense qu'on a aussi besoin d'histoire
pour le coup parce que je pense que
c'est aussi dans l'histoire de faire ce
c'est très dur aujourd'hui d'expliquer
que nous ne connaîtrons plus le climat
que nos enfants enfin nos parents que
nous-mêmes on a connu petit ça fait
bizarre de alors Sandrine Rousseau vous
avez publié mais il y a déjà un moment
avec Adélaïde bon par-delà l'androzen
vous croyez vraiment qu'il y a quelque
chose au-delà de l'androgène j'espère
bien oui
des petits hommes verts non j'y mets une
société de coopération d'égalité de
résilience et de sobriété et je pense
que précisément ce sera une société bien
plus heureuse que de courir après une
chimère genre de cœur vase doué vous
avez publié avec Henri Voron pour en
finir avec les histoires d'eau je sais
que récemment vous avez publié un
ouvrage sur la santé mais
ces histoires d'eau ça vous titille
toujours mais non et après j'ai écrit
les écolonnements donc quand on
s'intéresse
et c'est ma passion pour l'écologie qui
me conduit à critiquer l'écologie
politique merci je vous remercie
mesdames messieurs d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci à qui de LCP et
avant de nous quitter je vous soumets
cette pensée l'homme énergie qui réussit
c'est celui qui parvient à transformer
en réalité les fantaisies du désir c'est
de qui d'après vous aucune idée j'ai
choisi exprès un auteur pour mettre en
perspective ce débat c'est de Zigmund
Freud
[Musique]